huang like adele as of spider-man no way
home it's more like sorcerer supreme tom
holland's spider-man is unlike anything
we've seen before from the web slinger
on the big screen in earlier movies
peter parker often acted as a lone wolf
he worked by himself and never seemed to
encounter other superheroes in his world
even in new york city home to most of
the marvel universe's superheroes this
changed pretty drastically with the
character's introduction into the marvel
cinematic universe where he has had
plenty of opportunities to fight
alongside earth's mightiest heroes
captain
big fan of spider-man yeah we'll talk
about it later just hey everyone good
job
in captain america civil war and
spider-man homecoming he was a protege
of iron man in spider-man far from home
he had to try to live up to tony stark's
expectations in the aftermath of iron
man's death and in spider-man no way
home peter turns to a member of his old
avengers infinity war cohort dr strange
to help him out of a pinch as no way
home begins peter's dealing with the
ramifications of having his identity
exposed to the world he turns to the
bleeker street sorcerer to cast a spell
so that no one will remember that peter
parker and spider-man are one in the
same it's at this moment we get an
intriguing new bit of information about
a key player and it's something every
mcu fan maybe should have seen coming
after peter shows up doctor strange and
wong discuss the ethical and practical
ramifications of casting a spell that
will impact everyone on the planet
including themselves it's at this point
wang makes it known he is now the
sorcerer supreme and it makes total
sense in infinity war huang is left to
protect the sanctum sanctorum when ebony
ma takes strange prisoner while the
movie makes it unclear if wang is a
casualty of the blip the actor who plays
him benedict wong confirmed in a 2019
reddit ama that he would likely take
over as sorcerer's supreme although
strange was originally tapped to hold
the title he was gone for five years
courtesy of thanos naturally the title
had to go to someone else considering
everyone thought strange was permanently
dead the revelation about wong's new
status within the sorcerer hierarchy
provides new context to an exchange
featured in the no way home teaser
trailer don't cast that spell
it's too dangerous
fine
i won't
we now know that order isn't coming from
a pier it's coming from someone who's
effectively strange's boss what does
this mean for the future of the mcu
probably not much doctor strange still
has full control of his powers including
his ability to manipulate reality per
his whims wong will likely still be
sorcerer supreme going into doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness but
that likely won't stop strange from
messing with other realities and
interacting with scarlet witch along the
way it's simply a title change though
it's one that wong probably won't want
to give up anytime soon wang as the
sorcerer supreme makes sense but one
aspect of his new role that may have
fans scratching their heads is why such
a powerful individual spends their time
fighting in underground cage fights as
marvel fans will remember wong was part
of shaolin's super-powered tournament in
chongqi and the legend of the ten rings
such an act might make sense for a
sorcerer who's short on rent money for
the month but doesn't the sorcerer's
supreme have better things to do than
break the abomination out of a high
security prison to battle him in front
of a bunch of spectators and gamblers
maybe wang just loves the thrill of the
fight perhaps he's having trouble paying
off the homeowner's tax for the sanctum
sanctorum it's undoubtedly expensive
right smack dab in the middle of
manhattan either way it appears that
doctor strange isn't the only wizard
who's willing to bend the rules a little
bit the real question remains whether
huang will retain the title of
sorcerer's supreme or if strange will
take it back at some point in doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
time will tell
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]
you